[Music]
on this sunday night canada's prime
minister in ukraine
justin trudeau's surprise visit to keeve
touring the destruction and reopening
the canadian embassy the canadian flag
once again
will be flying over the streets of kiev
the battle for abortion rights we're not
just going to lay down and let the
supreme court take away our rights
protesters in the u.s take their fight
straight to the doorstep of supreme
court justices
vaccine nasal spray we sniff out a
possible new weapon against covid19
plus ahead by a century the growing
number of canadian centenarians who say
100 is the new 90. well it's not going
to be 50 60 70 80.
and you kept on going i kept on going
giving you 100 yes
global national
reporting tonight
jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us on a day the canadian prime minister
made a surprise visit to the ukrainian
capital justin trudeau arrived in kiev
flanked by the deputy prime minister and
foreign affairs minister they toured the
destruction in the nearby suburb of
urpin reopened the canadian embassy
which was closed in early february amid
fears of a russian invasion and then
trudeau held a joint press conference
with the ukrainian president
when i was in the opinion this morning
i saw just how
much
ukrainians can do standing against
a force
eight times as large as they were it is
an inspiration but i also saw the work
that we're going to have to do
altogether to rebuild those communities
to rebuild an even stronger future for
ukraine and that's exactly what we would
be there for
and to that end the prime minister also
announced new supports for ukraine and
more sanctions against russia our europe
bureau chief crystal gamansing has the
latest from keefe
jeff the day of this visit is
significant may 8 when europeans mark
allied nations defeating nazi germany
it's a sign of unity and support with
ukraine as it battles for its freedom in
europe's largest land war since 1945.
a show of confidence in ukraine's
capital as the canadian embassy gets
ready to reopen prime minister justin
trudeau along with his second in command
christian friedland and foreign affairs
minister melanie jolie did the honors of
raising the flag nearly three months
after the embassy shut down
thank you for staying
the moment was overwhelming for sir he
mayor who worked security at the embassy
for the last five years and remained on
duty every day
similar sense of duty has been
motivating ukrainians to defend their
country with a fierceness that has taken
many off guard
while touring around erpine just outside
of the capitol trudeau commented on the
resilience of ukrainians the visit was
under heavy guard and kept secret
specifically what did you see that you
haven't seen over the last 70 odd days
that stuck with you
i saw just
how much
ukrainians can do standing against
a force
eight times as large as they were
in defending
their homes defending
their land of pushing back against the
russian
illegal invasion trudeau came with more
than just supportive wards announcing
the removal of tariffs on all ukrainian
imports for one year 25 million dollars
for food security money for demining
programs plus more drone cameras
satellite imaging small arms and
munitions plus more sanctions on russia
canada will support ukraine as you seek
justice for your people who russia
is killing and brutalizing
with his country still engaged in a
bloody and horrific war ukraine's
president says he still needs specific
defensive weapons to ensure his
country's freedom but says like
lithuania latvia and estonia canada has
answered his calls and he counts the
country among a small group we cannot
ask from them anymore
so
today
we are hosting the leader
of the fourth country that we also
cannot ask for more ukraine's president
says he will be putting pressure on
other nations for more help and hopes
canada will act as a partner encouraging
others to step up
jeff crystal gomezing reporting in keeve
tonight thanks crystal
and some american diplomats also made a
temporary return to kiev today one month
after the u.s secretary of state
promised their embassy in the ukrainian
capital would reopen soon
this trip is being billed as a
diplomatic engagement and not an
official resumption of operations at the
american embassy officials say they hope
to fully reopen in the coming weeks
separately first lady jill biden made
her own surprise visit she crossed from
slovakia into southwestern ukraine for a
meeting with ukraine's first lady olena
zelenska
that high level diplomacy in kiev came
as fighting continued in the east of the
country more than 60 people are feared
dead after an airstrike hit a school
where people were taking shelter and the
ukrainian president warned to expect
more attacks in the coming hours as
russia prepares to mark a major military
anniversary abigail beeman reports
my son died in my hands life has no
meaning to me now says this woman as
mothers around the world celebrate
mother's day many in ukraine are
thinking of children lost her hope for
other mothers is to see their children
survive
some will more than 300 civilians have
now been rescued from the azov stall
steel plant in mariopol the city key to
moscow's efforts to create a land bridge
between the crimean peninsula and parts
of the eastern donbass region controlled
by russian-backed separatists
[Music]
as of regiment leaders say the steel
mill was still under intensive shelling
saturday and there are hundreds of
troops still inside many of them wounded
needing help
while in luhansk the death toll at this
school bombed by russia saturday has
climbed to as high as 60. 90 were
sheltering inside it is about staying in
power
and vladimir putin knows that in the
history of russia
when governments lost a war
they usually lost power
a very different scene in russia i think
that vladimir putin seems to be hung up
on may 9th and
i'm not quite sure why he's been so
foolish to be blunt rehearsals are
underway for putin's victory day
celebrations on monday a holiday
commemorating the soviet union's defeat
of nazi germany in the second world war
with speculation he could use the
opportunity to either ramp up fighting
or declare victory over ukraine i think
there's slightly too much optimism in
western capitals that the momentum is
going to stay on ukraine's side sunday
g7 leaders held a call with ukraine's
president as a group they're promising
to further isolate russia economically
as well as either ban or phase out
russian oil a lot more difficult for
european nations than north american but
they're promising to do so in a quote
timely fashion
jeff
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
the united states could be on the verge
of a seismic shift over how much say a
woman has over her own body democrats
are attempting to enshrine abortion
access into law after last week's leak
of a supreme court draft opinion that
seeks to overturn the landmark roe
versus wade ruling republican states are
also gearing up for a fight and as
reggie chichini explains any decision
that restricts abortion rights could
find itself on the opposite side of
popular opinion
fearful that a woman's decision over her
own body may be stripped away a
collective voice flooded into the
streets of the u.s over the weekend to
pressure lawmakers and courts to back
off we're not just going to lay down and
let the supreme court take away our
rights in washington d.c the protests
appeared at the front doors of two
conservative supreme court justices who
appear to back the right-leaning
majority in overturning roe versus wade
sending shock waves down the spines of
the medical community
part of what's so problematic about
these laws is that they violate our
obligation and our ethics that is now
putting lawmakers on the spot
we are going to say not on our watch
they can't duck it anymore eight months
after the house passed a bill on
abortion rights senate democrats will
bring a vote on similar legislation this
week and while the numbers aren't on
their side momentum could be if we are
not successful then we go to the ballot
box the majority of americans support
unfettered access to an abortion but
with the public split over where the
line should be drawn in terms of maximum
times to obtain the procedure the gop
will be left to navigate the data and
not erode anti-abortion support ahead of
the midterms we want to increase the
services for maternal health to increase
the
services for adoption services
arkansas's republican governor says
exemptions in cases of rape and incest
need to be a part of the debate but
that's not something all states intend
to do
politics aside doctor's main concern is
for the well-being of those whose
decisions might be made for them we're
going to keep trying to get our patients
connected with the care that they need
while a court decision is still weeks
away the battle over values only digs
deeper
reggie chikini global news washington
ocala has just completed an
investigation into its worst water
contamination crisis last fall fuel
leaked into the water supply leaving it
undrinkable for two months then in
january the water became contaminated
again from a different source heather
urex west reports on the cause and
concerns about clean drinking water in
canada's northernmost city
with the smell of fuel coming off their
drinking water last fall ocala residents
were left scrambling to find any safe
supply i think it is the biggest crisis
that the city has ever faced the
contamination came from an old fuel tank
buried underground near the city's water
treatment plant the contamination meant
every business and resident had to rely
on bottled water for weeks the fact that
this happened here in ocala in a major
city in canada in 2021 is very
disturbing the city worked quickly to
solve the problem but just a few weeks
later the water was contaminated again
about a month later we had another
contamination event which was
surprising to us as
you know we felt confident about the
remediation efforts that had happened
now an investigation has revealed what
went wrong finding that the two events
were unrelated the source the second
time a water sealant product improperly
installed seeped into the drinking
supply
but the back-to-back scares have
highlighted just how vulnerable canada's
arctic water infrastructure has become
especially as the north experiences the
fast-tracked impacts of climate change
what we're seeing that's a real a real
serious impact for callaway is the
permafrost degradation and so we're
getting a lot of water breaks and water
leaks in our distribution system the
city is also seeing wild fluctuations in
precipitation levels in both 2018 and
2019 the city declared water emergencies
because its reservoir levels became
dangerously low
last month the federal government
announced a 215 million dollar funding
promise to help a callaway improve its
water infrastructure system for the long
term a badly needed investment residents
hope will keep their water clean and
safe through the warming years ahead
heather urex west global news calgary
coming up bono in a bomb shelter u2's
surprise concert in ukraine
plus a proposed new weapon against covid
19 that's really on the nose
welcome back the emergence of new
covid19 variants has been a persistent
thorn in the side of vaccine
manufacturers the now dominant omicron
subvariants are better at spreading and
evading protection that's why some
scientists are now turning their
attention to a new preventative measure
they hope will tamper transmission jamie
morocco reports on covet 19 nasal sprays
ironed out and ready to go yeah we did
some practice runs with that as well dr
mark andre langawa and a team of
scientists at the university of ottawa
are trying to take on one of covet 19's
strongest attributes its ability to
spread their solution
a new vaccine you spray up your nose the
current vaccines deployed in canada the
mrna vaccines are excellent at
preventing severe disease
where they are
less effective is that preventing
transmission covet tends to enter
through the nose and throat a nasal
spray could allow the body to form
immunity at the mucous layer blocking it
from moving any further into the body
versus an intramuscular vaccine like the
current mrna shots which attack the
virus once it's already inside you what
slows down evolution is stopping the
number of replication events and you can
get good clearance or even sterilizing
immunity when your antibodies
immediately just
destroy the pathogen we already have
nasal vaccines for the flu but they
aren't without their issues sneezing or
swallowing while being treated can
impact efficacy and with little known
about mucosal immunity development can
be difficult michael russell an expert
in this specialization says producing
one will go a long way towards
preventing disease
no disease
no spread if you want to control
transmission by immunological means then
i think the only way you're going to do
that
is with a mucosal intranasal vaccine
globally there are 16 covenasal vaccines
in human trials including one in the
initial phase at the university of
calgary three others are already in
large scale human studies if proven safe
and effective nasal vaccines could be on
the market in months right now we're
just working on ourselves langlois and
his colleagues are still in the early
days of testing a nasal spray vaccine an
effective one should be a vaccine that
can be adapted to the various
variants of concern inching closer they
hope to creating the key experts say to
stopping kovit in its tracks
jamie marrocker global news toronto
still ahead the philippines heads to the
polls why its democracy could be at
stake
you are watching global national
the philippines is heading to the polls
monday to choose a new president as the
country's controversial populist leader
rodrigo duterte's six-year term comes to
a close the leading candidate to replace
him has a familiar name in the nation's
political history ferdinand marcos jr is
the son of the country's late dictator
and critics say he's winning support by
rewriting history with nearly a million
people of filipino descent living in
canada many here are watching with great
anticipation dan spector reports
there is a palpable sense of
anticipation among canadians with roots
in the philippines as the southeast
asian nation approaches a presidential
election where it seems no less than
democracy itself is at stake
why boom boom
we need the change in our country
unification that's a filipino this
montreal are unequivocal in her support
for ferdinand marcos jr known to
millions as bong bong who's taken a
commanding lead in the polls his father
ferdinand marcos senior was the deeply
divisive dictator and kleptocrat who
cracked down on dissent thrust the
country into martial law in the 70s
before his ouster and exile in the 80s
so how has a former first family with so
much political baggage prompted
reactions like this
the younger marcos has been accused of
running a massive misinformation
campaign to rewrite minimize and in some
cases completely dismiss his father's
record millions in the philippines seem
convinced and so are people in canada i
know i heard i read about all of the
stuff
but there's no problem with all those
things
this is the duster that i was wearing
when they arrested me this former
political prisoner says she was detained
tortured and sexually assaulted by
agents of the first marcos regime her is
just one of tens of thousands of similar
stories according to amnesty
international the fear is that political
opponents and dissenters will be treated
the same way under a new marcos regime
and the past erased the relatives proved
that they were killed summarily executed
tortured
human rights lawyer lenny robredo is
marcos's most serious challenger but
she's being relentlessly smeared on
social media and is about 20 points
behind in polls i see
millennial robredo
giving us
i think the principles of a good
governance
tennie rose diane dante is one of her
biggest supporters in montreal and got a
barrage of angry messages after she held
an event promoting robredo last month
being pink here being lenny robredo here
in montreal
you need a gun
she sees robredo as a hopeful step away
from a corrupt regime but if she were to
defeat marcos information machine it
would be a huge upset inspector global
news montreal
next 100 years and counting canadian
centenarians offer their secrets to a
long life
[Music]
canadians are getting older over the
past 20 years statistics canada reports
the number of seniors over 85 has
doubled to nearly nine hundred thousand
and that number is projected to hit two
and a half million in the next 25 years
and a growing number of canadians are
also entering what was once a highly
exclusive club mike drolet explains
it's a photo shoot 100 years in the
making and certainly not one janet
hester ever thought she'd take part in
well as i got to be 50 60 70 80
and you kept on going i kept on going
and giving you a hundred yes
centenarians used to be harder to find
but with modern medicine and healthy
living 100 has become the new 90. it
used to seem
almost like this miraculous idea of
living to a hundred it's now the life
expectancy of my own children statistics
canada only started collecting data on
centenarians in 2001 when there were
just over 3 500 across the country but
over the next decade that number almost
doubled and then doubled again over the
past 10 years
and if you separate by gender women are
almost five times as likely to reach 100
than men
why that is is debatable but the general
consensus among health professionals is
women have traditionally smoked less and
are more active later in life and it
doesn't need to be running a marathon or
it doesn't need to be some herculean
task that you're doing it really just
means getting up and move more the
active part certainly applies to 102
year old gertie behariel but that's it
i don't know how healthy i did
everything everybody else did smoked and
drank
all the things you weren't supposed to
all the things i wasn't supposed to do
what she has however is a keen wit or an
act of mind a key factor in the growing
number of canadians joining the
centenarian club it's still a big deal
and we make it a big deal
and they should because it's still a
pretty exclusive one
mike drolite global news toronto
and happy mother's day to all the
mothers grandmothers and great
grandmothers that is global national for
this sunday night i'm jeff semple
tonight we leave you with a surprise
concert inside a subway station turned
bomb shelter in kiev performed by u2's
bono and the edge
[Music]
pretty cool around 100 people were there
to watch the two members of the irish
rock band perform for about 40 minutes
bono gave a shout out to ukrainians
fighting for freedom against russia
saying they can take your lives but they
can never take your pride thanks for
watching donna friesen we'll be back
here at the anchor desk with you
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]